this is why produce content everyday if
you might be watching my content every
day and it might be this conversation
with us in the blog that is you know
it's very meta this might have been the
one this might have been the one on this
day because of a conversation here last
night because of the weather outside
because of a news headline because of
the patterns of how the for Instagram
posts came in your feed it might just be
the time you finally do what the [ __ ]
you're supposed to do
[Music]
right right things like going through
more like station
I get it I get it
that's exactly right like that's why I
came up with macro patience micro speed
right gotta go fast every day you gotta
go slow every year and that [ __ ] with
people you're asking a different
question you're asking when is the time
to jump in the pool when is the time to
kiss the boy when's the time you know to
get married you know you're talking
about like when's the time to take the
training wheels off the bike you know
when the time to [ __ ] live your life
that that's probably why I made content
the answer is I don't know nobody knows
there's no right answer there's that
moment in time this is why I produced
content every day it might be watching
my content every day and it might be
this conversation with us and vlog that
is you know it's very meta this might
have been the one this might have been
the one on this day because of a
conversation here last night because of
the weather outside because of a news
headline
because of the patterns of how the four
Instagram posts came in your feed it
might just be the time you finally do
what the [ __ ] you're supposed to do and
I think a lot of people think of it as
like quit your job and go do your
journey right things you're thinking
about others I think of it a little bit
different sometimes it's that's exactly
right sometimes it's like mm-hmm
I've been doing this nightlife and
t-shirt thing for seven years
why don't I go work for something smart
for a year reset why don't I go travel
why don't I sell my home that I don't
use 90% of take that money get an
apartment and then do something with
that money so to me it's not just like
the fancy sizzle of like now jump into
the rest of your life it's also like
it's also like awed it understand what
you need break up with that person marry
that person you know you know start your
career go back to corporate for an hour
okay a year or two to reset like you
know just do it's the indecisiveness
it's the indecisiveness that is the
poison because you can always undo
the biggest thing about doing is the
undoing that people don't see I'm always
like okay good and then like if you fail
go back but people don't want the
Scarlet Letter they don't want the
judgment this is why you have to tune
everything out because if you go and
judge start your t-shirt brand or your
pin brand or your video blog and it
fails if you just think you can go back
to it well that sounds cool but if you
feel like oh but then everybody's gonna
clown on me and see this ain't like then
you're if you're if you're pessimistic
mom's okay like see I told you you could
never do it if you can't get over that
then you're [ __ ] stuck you're not
gonna change evolution and Technology
you just need to figure out how to ride
it so it doesn't kill you and by the way
I mean this um you know collecting the
energy of the room thinking about what
we talked about here I mean this I don't
think it's bad if you're not capable or
willing to up your game put in the work
hustle you should lose it's how you won
but everybody fights hard for 30 years
and I want to hold up athletes you know
you know what I hate about business that
I love about athletes when you're the
best athlete in the world you get the
results when you get to 36 and a younger
lion comes along you lose in business we
have this weird [ __ ] that we are
supposed to be rewarded at the end [ __ ]
you I mean it
[ __ ] you you didn't [ __ ] take this
internet serious for the last 20 years
why the [ __ ] should you be rewarded
yeah [ __ ] that's the game that's the
game what you should be rewarded that
you understood some town was gonna be
good and you got a great 30-year lease
and you locked in and you got rewarded
for that then why shouldn't you be
[ __ ] not rewarded for [ __ ]
completely dismissing the internet as
this little thing it's the [ __ ] world
this is fake this is secondary this is
primary eat it live it understand it
that's the truth
you don't like it [ __ ] deal with the
ramifications you're gonna lose
[Music]
I'll be welcome Jordan Palmer Gary
Vaynerchuk Thank You Taylor audio good
everyone hear me all right
beatbox thank you so much Gary thank you
so much for joining us man we'll starve
it in like Adam somebody who's at a
million somebody who's at ten and
somebody who's at 50 depending on where
they're at like what's a piece of advice
you'd give to somebody who's at the
early stage of a million somebodies
we're right in the middle and then
somebody who's really looking to scale
you know I think first of all I think to
really answer it honestly and it's a
little more heady but it's the truth if
I was sitting with one of you right now
for five minutes I'd want to know what
are you trying to do you know like you
know what you're trying to accomplish is
just an unbelievably important part I
think we get caught up in going from 1
to 5 to 5 to 10 to 10 to 20 you know you
get so caught up in the game it's like
the biggest reason I think people
struggling social media literally people
are pandering to a like on an Instagram
post not unnecessarily what they're
trying to do so I think first and
foremost at a macro you need to
understand are you actually building
your business to sell it because then
you may care about you know the ebody
and how much profit you're making and so
what that advice is important
vaynermedia is gonna do 170 million
dollars and I'm not gonna make a penny
like I'm trying to pour it all back in
literally we may make zero profit this
year that it's because I don't want to
sell it tomorrow and I don't need the
dividends from the profits in the year
to change my lifestyle so I mean this
it's really important you have to know
what you're doing then like why you're
doing it and by the way you can change
your mind you could be sitting near me
like I'm gonna change the world
but you know great and then of two years
you want to buy an island that's great
and everything in between so first what
hey gray my name is Johnny hey Jen a
year ago well I'm currently a she was
still self-employed but a year ago I was
self-employed
I hated it yeah I found your content I I
was depressed and I had a lot of excuses
and in the last year I you have
completely changed the way I think I've
gotten rid of all my excuses I'm
actually in contention for an internship
here I don't even have
yet I'm 27 so I've got three years to
eat [ __ ] I and I I just want you know I
would gently appreciate your content so
much thank you
rather the other being number one to a
small pool I'm Ruby number 13 in a big
one super [ __ ] smart thank you
you're welcome brother that means a lot
to me you know it's funny I really
appreciate that and it was one of the
you know one of the great things about
producing content every day and vlogging
is you stumble on [ __ ] you know this
what you you know and I'm as emotional
about this as you are it's [ __ ] crazy
like we built entrepreneurship up too
much the other way we overcorrected and
you've got a lot of everybody under
[ __ ] 25 thinks they need to be an
entrepreneur the fact that the fact that
that hit you it's real man like man I
wish I almost wish I was number 13 of
Facebook you know like like it makes me
super happy it's all about
self-awareness
it's my opening line was about
self-awareness what are you up to do you
know meet people bro you know what my
new one on this is because the reason
I'm emotional about this is maybe you
got [ __ ] trucks too you know it's
super powerful I think I'm also getting
a little bit more emotional because that
one you can't I mean
look my life is so [ __ ] awesome right
now like do you know what it feels like
to get twenty thousand messages a day of
like you made my life better it's just
[ __ ] you know you just I don't even
know how to almost quant like it's
almost difficult to like comprehend I've
got a new one that has been really like
kind of like it's similar to that and
like I know that it's going to work I
know that I know that there's so much
opportunity for people to become more
self-aware and figure themselves out and
it's gonna help so much and the new one
I figured out is there are so many
people that would be so much happier
making 27 thousand dollars less a year
and the only thing they have to do is
sell their current home where they only
use 18 percent of the home anyway and
baha'i a home that has two less bedrooms
so they don't have to have the job that
is paying to maintain the lifestyle that
they've propped up for themselves
and their life will be like
disproportionately better I'm gonna
[ __ ] pound that content I'm gonna
figure out some clever way to really
penetrate similar to close your eyes
until you're 29 [ __ ] that people
remember I'm gonna [ __ ] change the
game on this one cuz it's a big one
cuz there's a lot more people living
that than what you were like as many
entrepreneurs as they are that should be
the employees there's way more people
that basically build a life around how
much they're earning get to a place
where they hate what they're doing to
earn have the opportunity to still do
something that earns twenty thousand
less that they love but they're bold and
handcuffed by worrying about what car
they drive or where their house is
because they actually care about other
people's opinions and nobody has the
gear to take a step backwards the
inability to take a step back to take
step four steps forward in happiness
based on other people's opinions of
watching you take a step back blows my
[ __ ] face off
[Music]